you've likely heard by now that the
world economic Forum wants to make you
eat bugs live in a pod and owe nothing
and all of that is true but the wef is
taking some more immediate and concrete
steps to upend your life one such power
play is something called Safety by
Design which is probably the biggest big
tet threat that you have never heard of
safety by Design is the hobby horse of a
woman named Julie Inman Grant she's just
a bureaucrat she's the Australian
e-safety commissioner who went viral
last year in Davos at the world economic
Forum when she proposed a recalibration
of free speech
we are finding ourselves in a place
um where we're we have increasing
polarization everywhere and everything
feels binary when it doesn't need to be
so I think we're going to have to think
about a recalibration of a whole range
of human rights that are playing out
online you know from freedom of speech
to the freedom to you know to be free
from online violence or the right of
data protection to the right to child
dignity
since then Grant has taken significant
steps in collaboration with the wef to
make their recalibration a reality
safety by Design is the notion that
government Regulators can't possibly
keep up with all the bad things
confronting people online
not just real problems like criminal
threats and fraud and child pornography
and things like that but a much broader
array of topics and opinions that
leftists deem harmful so these safety by
Design solution is to take the burden of
suppressing those things off of The
Regulators out of the government
agencies and just build liberals
regulatory preferences into the design
code of the tech platforms themselves
here's how it works
safety by Design to me is key this is
putting the responsibility back it's
it's it's having companies
um from the leadership from the top down
prioritize safety build it in at the
front end and
um
you know now we have the basic Online
safety expectations which basically lay
out
um the duty of care and what we respect
the interactive services to be doing as
a right to or a license to operate in
our country
so in order to operate in Australia
they've they've got to build the liberal
regulatory preferences into the code of
the platforms otherwise the platforms
don't get to operate in Australia but
safety by Design is not merely being
implemented in Australia because Grant
serves on a bunch of boards for the wef
and her plan in perfect alignment with
the broader globalist goals of Davos is
to export this scheme all around the
world to control speech in all sorts of
categories
not just the threats and the fraud and
the porn and media entertainment even
Sports
through safety by Design Grant and the
wef intend and have been open about
their intent to push diversity equity
and inclusion
to suppress what they call
misinformation and hate speech all of
which is gobbledygook talk for censoring
conservatives and promoting liberals and
if they can convince just a handful of
countries to implement these sorts of
policies
that could tip the scales to force big
Tech's hand to implement it for everyone
it's not that you need to convince every
country in the world to adopt this stuff
if you convince a few of them frankly
even if you just convince one of them
that is going to send a signal to Big
Tech to say okay look we're not going to
build completely separate platforms for
Australia and let's say Canada and the
US and France and then separate separate
platforms for all the rest of the
countries so okay we'll do what
Australia wants us to do and then safety
by Design governs the speech for
everybody people are posting all sorts
of conspiracy theories to social media
as the wef's annual meeting goes on in
Davao Switzerland right now
but if the globalists get their way
we won't see those conspiracy facts
online for much longer I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Lucky Jacks
who says if we could harness even the
fumes from these windbags at the wef we
could power the entire world for a year
for free at least a year I think
actually you're not being nearly
optimistic enough I think we could
probably power the world for a decade
okay
and we we could avoid the death of our
culture the death that the globalists
tell us is coming to all of humanity if
we don't give them all of our rights and
our political power and our cars and our
stoves and all the rest of it okay I
don't think the world is going to end in
five minutes as these people scare us
into thinking
but I do think that you will die and you
will die sooner than you think and
that's why you need to check out epic
will right now go to epicwell.com use
promo code Knowles it can be very tough
to stick to your New Year's resolution
you set out with lofty goals you stick
to them for two weeks then you fall
right back into your old bad habits
lucky for you I have a goal that you can
accomplish today complete your will with
epic will for just 119 dollars and in as
little as five minutes epic will can
help you create your last will and
testament living will and even Health
Care power of attorney their
step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy all you need to do is
fill in the blanks it's very very
important to have a will for a long time
I did not have a will and I was very
irresponsible because then what would
happen to my stuff what would happen to
my family what happened to my kids
fifty percent of Americans don't have a
will choose today to be in the smarter
half go to epicwill.com use promo code
noltskin w-l-e-s to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that's
epicwill.com promo code nulls
k-n-o-w-l-e
s
all sorts of conspiracy theories here
this here's a conspiracy theory
this comes from AP News
AP news says says the world economic
Forum which opens Monday
is slated to take on pressing Global
issues but online
it has become a target of bizarre claims
from a growing chorus who believe it
involves a group of Elites manipulating
events for their own benefit we'll put a
pause right there
yes there are right-wingers who say that
about the world economic forum
that is what the world economic Forum
says about itself that is the entire
raison d'etre of the world economic
forum is to gather Global Elites to
change the world to become masters of
the future that's what klausch Bob says
the founder and
king of the world economic forum
it's it's a conspiracy fact it is a
theory about a conspiracy but the
conspiracy is real and so the the libs
are very upset about this they say this
isn't a conspiracy that's playing out on
the extreme fringes that's according to
Alex friedfeld a researcher with the
Anti-Defamation League who studies
anti-government extremism we'll put a
pause right there the Anti-Defamation
League isn't that the group that that
talks about anti-semitism
and accuses people that they don't like
of anti-Semitism why are they now
talking about
Davos why are they not talking about the
world economic Forum why are they upset
when people point out that we don't want
to eat the bugs and live in the pods and
and have all our property taken away by
Cloud Schwab who's not a Jew he's a
German
he says this is very very bad this is
we're seeing this
on mainstream social media platforms
being shared by regular Americans we
were seeing it being spread by
mainstream media figures right on their
Prime Time news on their nightly
networks oh no
Tara it's a crazy conspiracy theory
I mentioned on the show yesterday if you
say that Davos is where the elites get
together to completely transform society
and change the future
and that's a good thing
then you're a good wonderful person
you're insightful you keep up with the
news if you say the exact same thing
but you conclude it with
and that's a bad thing then you're a
crazy Fringe wild conspiracy theorist
Alex Jones you got the the tin foil hats
on you probably worry about Chemtrails
and gay frogs
that's it's what Michael Anton at the
Claremont Institute calls the
celebration Parallax the the libs are
allowed to tell you their plans
and celebrate it but you can't repeat to
them the very things that they just told
you if if you were going to criticize it
that's one tactic one tactic that the
libs have been using to downplay what's
going on in Davos is to say well this is
just a crazy conspiracy theory then the
other tactic that they've used and it's
really only started this year
is they say oh that's stuff that's going
on in Davos it's not a big deal I saw a
headline but I think it was in CNN so
the real story of what's going on in
Davos is the world economic Forum it's
actually losing its influence yeah
people don't they don't care about that
anymore it's not
it's not a big you guys are worried
about some crazy conspiracy theory not
the real real stories they have way less
power than they ever did
I don't know
2700 bigwig attendees from 130 countries
116 billionaires and 52 heads of state
and they don't have any power
I don't know
the mainstream media The Establishment
press seem real eager these days to play
Down the influence of Davos but you just
heard one example just one and this is
one little tiny example of how the wef
operates
it brings together influential people
who all have the same liberal left-wing
Progressive agenda
then they all trade influence and they
all work on each other's power and it's
people in the private sector and in the
government sector the point of Davos is
to bring those two sectors together
because if you bring those two sectors
together then sometimes the private
sector can do the Dirty Work of the
government and people have no recourse
against the private sector this is what
happens when the government uses
allegedly private corporations like
Facebook Twitter and Google to to censor
Americans Well it can't be a First
Amendment violation if the FBI just had
a secret meeting with some Facebook exec
and said hey censor censor the hunter
Biden laptop story
I mean I think it is a First Amendment
violation but they have plausible
deniability they said no it's a private
company private company has no First
Amendment responsibility to protect your
speech but really it's the government
that was pressuring the social media
companies
or you will see corporate influence onto
the government
pushing massive deregulation not for the
small business owners not for the mom
and pops for all the people who are in
the rooms at Davos
that you see it play out in real time
some random Australian bureaucrat
through the power that she wields among
liberal globalist networks is currently
in the process of changing the way
that the internet operates on
potentially the biggest platforms on the
internet
to decide what things you're allowed to
say to ban hate speech are you going to
be allowed to say in five years are you
going to be allowed to say on the
internet that a boy is a boy and a girl
is a girl maybe you're barely allowed to
say it now
but no they they have no influence what
do you pay no attention to the man
behind the curtain we have got to pay
attention to what the Davos types to
what the globalists are saying what
they're predicting about the future
because they have an outsized amount of
influence to make those predictions come
true one prediction comes from the head
of the World Health Organization
warning of the next epidemic mark it
down here it is breaking news new
epidemic dropped get ready for more
social distancing and masks and losing
your job and giving up your money giving
up your rights which epidemic is it this
time it is a drum roll please
tuberculosis
one of the most practical sort of
economically effective and human
life-saving effective ways of making the
world
more prepared for future pandemics would
actually be to turbocharge the fight
against TB this is the disease of the
poor as as Peter said
um it's not the problem of the high
income countries when do we stop this
Behavior it's only when the rich
countries affected that then becomes a
serious issue it's a matter of time but
sooner or later of course those
countries who think that will not come
to them as a problem May Come even
imagine the extreme disease resistance
TB
that it's already coming
sooner or later it may come
now had we not just lived through the
three years that we just lived through
had the who not been caught with its
hand in the cookie jar caught red-handed
caught mixing metaphors like I'm doing
right now
in in a state of utter corruption when
it came to covid First helping China
cover it up cover up the the the
outbreak of the virus then helping China
cover up where the virus came from going
along with the BS ridiculous story that
it came from a bad batch of bat soup at
the Wuhan wet Market when in fact it
almost certainly came from the Wuhan
Institute of virology in fact with
research the likes of which the United
States was funding right there at the
Wuhan Institute if the who had any
credibility at all and if the world
economic Forum were not so cartoonishly
villainous in its designs and in its
overall demeanor then you might listen
to that and say oh wow that's scary I
guess we better prepare I sure don't
want to get tuberculosis
but
knowing what we know about The Who and
Mr Tedros it sounds less like a
prediction and more like a threat
sounds less like a prediction more like
a promise sooner or later
it may come
and now you've got the terrible awful
conspiracy theorists you know never
believe the conspiracy theorists about
anything now they're posting all over
social media
because they point out that bioentech
has announced clinical trials of an mRNA
vaccine for tuberculosis apparently
developed with the Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation that will begin or I
suppose at this point that did begin in
2022
I don't know anything about this
potential mRNA vaccine I do know that
that scientists are now working overtime
to apply the MRNA vaccine technology
which has had so many problems to all
sorts of other viruses so don't know
anything about this may or may not be
the case that they've got this vaccine
but the re I don't even mention it to
say anything about some potential mRNA
treatment for TB the the reason I
mention it is because
it is the behavior of these people of
the people in Davos
that that explains why people have all
sorts of terrible crazy conspiracies
about them
because the conspiracy theories have
often proven true
and because the world economic forum is
a conspiracy by definition that is the
whole point of it is you get a bunch of
people together who are very powerful
and you have them all work together to
decide the fate of the world whether you
want it or not
it's a conspiracy out in the open
it's a conspiracy
that is that is airing on TV the the
Revolution Will in fact be televised and
a lot of people won't do anything about
it my question for Tedros my question
for the people predicting
the next epidemic is
are you going to stop it before it
happens not are you going to lock us all
down and take away our businesses and
shut down our churches and upend our
societies after it happens but are you
going to stop it before it happens my
question for the globalists and Davos is
are you people really the Masters of the
Universe or not
because you present yourselves as the
Masters of the Universe who through your
own unfettered reason your Brilliance
the likes of which we've never seen in
all of history Aristotle Plato Thomas
Aquinas those guys are all dummies
compared to you you all figured it out
you've mastered the future you're going
to conquer death you're gonna you're
going to go in you're gonna edit our
genes you're gonna recreate Humanity not
just culture but our very biology okay
if you want me to trust you to do that
then you better be able to live up to
those promises that you that you shall
be as Gods so can you stop a virus
outbreak
I see no evidence of that in fact from
the behavior of these sorts of
globalists I see them exacerbating a lot
more problems than they're fixing I see
them funding gain of function research
at the Wuhan Institute of virology on
back coronaviruses that almost certainly
caused the outbreak of that pandemic
that they exploited to shut us down for
three years which they then called a
rare but narrow opportunity for a great
reset of our whole society what a
wonderful turn that could be and then
they applied their genius to create
these vaccines in a in a mad rush that
they told us were totally safe and
effective and now people are dropping
debt of Strokes blood clots heart
problems
people are getting nerve damage all the
rest of it
are you the Masters of the Universe or
not if you're not that's fine I don't
think you're the Masters of the Universe
but then stop
messing with our societies
stop messing with our very selves
more predictions coming out of Davos
another prediction promise or threat
there's going to be a big Cyber attack
we're here today to share the findings
of the world economic forums Global
Security Outlook report 2023.
this is a result of research and
collaboration with the forms communities
and our partner Accenture in which we've
interviewed and sought input from over
300 Executives globally the most
striking finding that we found is that
93 percent of cyber leaders
and 86 percent of cyber Business Leaders
believe that the geopolitical
instability makes a catastrophic cyber
event likely in the next two years
a catastrophic cyber event is likely in
the next years
maybe it is maybe it isn't
are these people going to stop it
if they if they can't stop it they don't
seem quite so omnipotent as they present
themselves are these people going to
cause it
are some of them going to cause it if
they cause it they don't seem quite so
omnibenevolent as they present
themselves they seem like pretty false
gods and yet they want to rewrite
Humanity
itself
see a clip this is put out by the world
economic Forum rewriting the code of
Life Gene editing technology can change
a whole organism could could enhance our
existence
to materials fashion we need to fix the
economy redesigning organisms for
beneficial purposes it's going to allow
us to not just edit genomes but also and
importantly write a new code for Life
we'll have right level permissions we
already started to see some of that this
year covid-19 vaccines they make use of
engineered code in the form of messenger
RNA
technology will cut out unwanted sights
and sounds but on the horizon are
diminished reality glasses that look
very much like what I'm wearing that
would allow you to remove things from
your point of view from your view
whether that's garbage uh or other
people
I did not believe that clip when I saw
it I said this has to be fake they cast
some woman it's a hoax I don't believe
it I looked it up it's real
the concept of diminished reality
glasses
where are rulers they're not going to
clean the garbage out of our society
they're just going to put on blindfolds
basically they're just gonna they're
going to Blind us so we don't see it
anymore that's a plan being pushed by
the one of the most elite and exclusive
clubs on planet Earth
do you trust these people to be your new
Gods some people do some people atheists
who don't believe in the real God they
say well these people are so smart
they're so genius they're billionaires
they run the world and that so yeah if
they can go into my into my DNA and hack
it oh jab me baby let's do it let's make
it happen come on I want augmented
reality and diminished reality get that
trash out of there pump me full of drugs
make me live in a video game put me in
the Pod I'll eat the bugs whatever I
don't care do do you really want to live
in a world in which these people are
Gods I I for one call me crazy I for one
to prefer to live in the world where God
is God I trust God more than I trust
these people I'm fine with medical
advances that can
cure diseases and deficiencies because
we live in a fallen world and everyone
encounters some kinds of flaws and
errors
but do I want to rewrite what a human is
period do I want to go in and enhance
what a human being is no I don't think
that I'm going to improve very much on
God's design and I am sure as hell
convinced that those people are not
going to improve on God's design at all
but if I got to choose between Gods I'm
picking the real one speaking of
religion a professor has just lost her
job
because she showed a picture of Muhammad
in class
Dr Erica Lopez Prater
I showed images in a course on Islamic
art
Islamic art
Muhammad you would think that these
things go together most people know
that a lot of Muslims find images of
physical depictions of Muhammad to be
sacrilegious and the teacher
acknowledged this apparently the teacher
gave a sort of warning beforehand and
said hey some people might find this
offensive but it's a course on Islamic
Art and so I'm going to show Islamic Art
okay and because she taught this
she's been fired a senior student
complained to school leaders
who decided to fire the teacher they
said
this is what David Everett who is the
Hamline University Hamlin Hamline not
your associate vice president for
inclusive excellence
it reads like a Dilbert cartoon it reads
like an absolute joke David ambrit who
has got this completely useless woke job
where he takes tuition money to create
problems he says in lieu of this
incident it was decided it was best that
this faculty member was no longer part
of the Hamline community
first of all
David Everett might know a lot about
inclusive Excellence he does not know
very much about the English language in
loot what does that mean does he mean in
light of this incident in lieu of means
instead of this incident
but he doesn't know that he doesn't know
anything about basic English but he
knows a lot about woke ideology that's
that's true of many college graduates
these days I guess it's true of some
teachers it's definitely true of these
know-nothing administrators in lieu of
this incident we felt it was best and so
what did the ham Hamlin Hamline vice
vice president rather than easy Miller
said it is not our intent to place blame
rather it is our intent to note that in
the classroom incident where an image
forbidden for Muslims to look upon was
projected on a screen and left for many
minutes not just several minutes many
minutes respect for the observant Muslim
Students in that classroom should have
superseded
academic freedom
okay
you're going to hear a lot of
conservative commentators say this is
outrageous
we have a commitment to academic freedom
and no nothing should supersede academic
freedom that's not my point of view I
don't even think that's a conservative
point of view in fact the modern
conservative movement which many if not
most people credit with beginning by a
book by William F Buckley Jr called God
and man at Yale that whole book was
making fun of academic freedom the
subtitle was the superstitions of
academic freedom I don't think there's
any such thing as academic freedom I
don't think teachers have any right to
teach whatever they want in the
classroom
I do think that this professor had a
right and frankly an obligation to
present images including images like
this one in a course on Islamic art
or at least certainly was within her
rights to do that if she didn't have an
outright obligation to do so
but I'm I'm not denying that Muslim
Students might have been offended and
they might have considered it
sacrilegious I consider it sacrilegious
I'm a Christian I consider it
sacrilegious when people deny the
Divinity of Christ I consider that to be
very sacrilegious okay I bet a Jewish
student would consider it sacrilegious
if at a I don't know a religious studies
uh party a religious studies happy hour
with with a lot of Jewish students
present they serve shellfish and bacon I
I could see how a Jewish student would
maybe be offended by that okay
we live in a pluralistic society that is
a fact and we all make
certain kinds of conciliations and come
to a sort of kind of imperfect agreement
where we
are able to get along with each other
I would be more than happy seeing laws
against
the this kind of offensive material
beefed up a little bit I do not believe
that the satanists have any right to put
up a Baphomet statue in a state capitol
or a courthouse as many of them contend
I don't think the founding fathers ever
believed that that was the case in fact
we had blasphemy laws on the books in
this country for most of our nation's
history in fact they're still in the
books in a number of states even today
I think it would be great I think it
would be a good thing in this country if
we offered people of different religious
views far greater respect than we do in
our extremely atheistic culture
but we can't be just Banning images of
Muhammad in Islamic Art classrooms okay
in this University I promise you a
teacher could get up and blaspheme Jesus
could mock the god of the Bible could
specifically mock God in the Old
Testament mock the ancient Israelites
could could say it's all of ridiculous
stupid made-up story but make contrived
by a bunch of lunatics who were afraid
of a magical Sky daddy I've had a number
of professors
certainly many professors around the
country have done that I bet a number of
professors at this school have probably
done that you wouldn't hear boo about it
but because it is Politically Incorrect
to in any way disparage an image of
Muhammad or in any way to transgress
some practice of Islam
forget about Christianity forget about
Judaism that's the only reason they did
it they're not doing it to protect
Muslims they're doing it to protect
political correctness
absolutely outrageous and they're
they're doing it to further a leftist
political agenda they're using the
Muslims to do that but they don't they
don't really care about the Muslims they
don't believe in Allah any more than
they believe in the god of the Old
Testament or the god understood in
Christianity and worshiped by Christians
speaking of matters of life and death
you know I've got a little bit of a
hobby horse
I referred earlier to the Hobby Horse of
that world economic forum lady
I've got a little bit of a hobby horse
myself and I got it from my wife sweet
little Elisa and that hobby horse would
be
seed oils
I listen I've never been convinced
of any fad nutritional diet stuff ever
in my life I thought the Atkins thing
was crazy I thought all the the Paleo
the keto all these different I always
think they're all very silly but there
is one
nutritional fashion that I'm completely
bought into seed oils
canola oil palm seed oil rape seed oil
it's called rapeseed oil for goodness
sakes
all these these gross seed oils that
cropped up in the last 30 years and
replaced good oils like olive oil
replace good tasting butter
all the rest of it I am totally
anti-seed oil I was thinking about the
evolution of conservatism the other day
I thought what how is conservatism
changed
in the 18th century it was about
opposing revolution in the 19th century
it was about defending tradition in the
20th century it was about preserving
Liberty today as far as I'm concerned
one of the one of the most exciting
motivators of the conservative spirit is
just freaking hating seed oils it's so
funny it's it's kind of an internety
you're you know you're paying too close
attention to politics thing right now
it's going mainstream it's I know it's
going mainstream it even appeared
on a very popular TV show
what's the worst thing out there to cook
with
you know this is a really controversial
thing I'm gonna be honest and there's a
huge controversy right now about
processed seed oils um which are
relatively new in the food supply and
have taken off as rates of obesity and
other problems have taken off
um so some people think that processed
seed oils might be bad for us others
argue no they're not there's a
difference in omega-3 versus omega-6
fatty acids in them seed oils tend to be
very high in omega-6 fatty acids which
might be more inflammatory
that was Live with Kelly and Ryan that
is a very mainstream TV show and they
are just throwing a ton of shade at seed
oils why do I like the seed oil thing
one I I'm pretty convinced that it's
true that seed oils are not the best for
you but the reason I really like it
politically is
that it's it's not really about the seed
oils the seed oil hatred is a sign for a
broader political view
when someone comes up to me and they say
Michael I hate seed oils I I can tell
you
that who that person voted for I can
tell you how that person stands on the
major issues I can probably broadly tell
you that person's religious views I can
tell you which people in the government
that person trusts and doesn't I could
tell you a lot about even even though
we're talking about canola oil
it's sort of like yoga
it's like yoga in the sense that it's
not 100 correct as a predictor but if
someone is really really into yoga that
person is probably a lib I know that
there are white conservative girls who
do yoga I know it's a it's a
conversation for another day okay but
the majority of people who are super
duper into yoga in the United States are
big Libs because yoga offers an
alternative spiritual vision an
alternative religious practice is just a
religious practice for people who reject
the traditional religious practices and
spiritual vision of the West
because it it satisfies certain longings
and
speaks to all sorts of of political
issues
even if it doesn't seem to do so
directly
I love these signs because even if they
seem completely out of left field they
suggest that there is a kind of
coherence to put people's religious
views I remember one time I met Ann
Coulter in college and at the time I I
was I was I think I was pro-abortion at
the time or I was weakening on it I was
think rethinking about the issue and I
was maybe in the midst of that and Ann
Coulter said look if you're ever
debating between which of two
Republicans to vote for
you got one who's pro-life you got one
who's pro-abortion and all you care
about is lowering your taxes
vote for the pro-life Republican he will
lower your taxes more
and that was a really really insightful
comment
seems like abortion and taxes have very
little to do with one another but they
do share a certain base that those two
issues derive from the same kind of
basic understanding of the human person
is what kind of Rights we ought to have
to our own property what respect we
ought to have for Life what skepticism
we ought to have from against unjust
powers
that he that person will lower your
taxes
more that there's a kind of coherence to
these views very often you'll hear
people in the middle and the libs and
the squishes say come on we don't need
to all agree as one party or anything
like that we can have a view on this
over here and a view on that from this
other party and if you and that's true
but you won't make sense you can do but
it's bet it's much better to make sense
you know what makes sense buying
Jeremy's razors Jeremy's razors is
offering a giant discount right now 40
off on all Razer subscriptions why
I'm glad you asked I'm glad I asked one
year ago today Joe Biden tried to force
vaccines on just about everybody here is
what Jeremy co-ceo of the daily wire had
to say about that
we won't be enforcing Joe Biden's
unconstitutional and tyrannical vaccine
mandate that's it we'll use every tool
at our disposal including legal action
to resist
yes that's the same Jeremy from Jeremy's
razors who you may remember
from this viral commercial
oh
did you see any other CEOs out there
publicly suing the government on your
behalf no
just Jeremy and the best part about it
is we won
the Biden vaccine mandate is as good as
dead we said do not comply and you did
not comply in fact over a million of you
signed our petition saying as much and
today together we kicked the
government's ass
so are you going to keep buying from
those other guys or from the guy who
sued the government on your behalf and
won and for all the ladies out there
give your man something else to smile
about every time that he picks up at
Jeremy's razor he'll remember just how
much you care trust me if he listens to
this show too he will appreciate you
even more and if he doesn't listen to
this show leave that man he's not a good
man he is not he does not have good
judgment we will make it even easier for
you switch right now and get 40 off on
your razer subscriptions at Jeremy's
racers.com
speaking of hippie stuff
Greta
Saint Greta of the Blessed sailboat I
know she sounds kind of Irish I'm trying
to do a Swedish I don't know how to do I
don't know okay I'm not
I'll work on it we'll try it again next
time Saint Greta
was just arrested
she was arrested by law enforcement in
Germany
I would have expected that she would
have gone to Davos either to appear at
the world economic Forum or to protest
the world economic Forum even though the
world economic Forum loves Greta but
that didn't happen because she was
arrested in Germany
she was protesting the expansion of a
coal mine in Western Germany and
according to Reuters she was warned by
police that she would be removed by
force if she did not vacate the mine
site and what did Saint Greta do she did
not vacate the Mayan's site and so what
happened she was dragged off by police
marking I believe the first time that
Greta has ever been arrested
I assume she would have been arrested as
a teenager for skipping school for like
180 days in a row but no I don't know
maybe the laws are different over there
in Sweden in America I think that would
have happened truancy laws but this
apparently was the first time she was
arrested
and
what the libs have said now is it's time
for many more of us to stand up and risk
arrest for the sake of being a livable
planet that's right she stood up to
power except some video came out not
just of her arrest where they're
dragging her off but video of a little
bit before the arrest
when Greta is
paling around with the cops
and actually posing for photos with them
you see everybody Smiles giggling
taking some photos all these great just
laughing having a grant okay but then
photos come together strains at her face
a little bit
maybe the cops posing
and they're posing holding her arm and
her hand for the reporters
she's there looking defiant cops aren't
they're not actually arresting her
they're just posing and then they
finally walk with her in the position of
arresting her
some are suggesting that this was all a
stunt cooked up by Greta thunberg that
these weren't real police officers that
they were just men wearing costumes I
don't think that's true I bet I don't
know for sure but I bet those were real
cops
no no the explanation for this photo op
followed by a
fake arrest I guess a technically a real
arrest but then they released her
immediately they just checked her
identity and let her go and the whole
thing was just such a fraud
the real explanation is far darker than
Greta paid some actors Jesse Smollett
Style the real explanation is that
they're all on the same side
Greta and the police are pretending that
they're on opposite sides and they're
fighting but they're not they're on the
same side this is why it's always such a
farce when Greta protests at things like
the world economic Forum or any other
liberal event says you're not going far
enough the libs love that the libs love
the the pressure from the left
to give them an opportunity to seize
even more control and pursue an even
more radical agenda than they were
already doing
gives them the excuse to say well we're
getting popular pressure from Saint Mary
to have the Blessed sailboat and so
we've we've got to do this sort of thing
you don't need a conspiracy theory for
that this is how the system works
there is the appearance of opposition
but
very often it's simply that it's a
facade and the people who appear to be
locked locking horns fighting to the
death they're really paddling around
they're really on the same team
you see this from the Republicans who
cheer on the globalists at Davos there's
a republican Congressman Maria Salazar
who showed up through the world economic
forum
not to defend American National
sovereignty not to say that we won't eat
the bugs and live in the pods give away
all our property to clash Bob no she
showed up there
to demand dignity
for illegal aliens in America
the party has been able to do
overhaul of the immigration system
because not only we need those hands
like the Congress that like us a senator
was saying but we need to also give
dignity to those people who are in the
country and those are the people that I
represent we're talking about 13 15
million people who are most of them
Hispanics I would say 85 percent who
speak my language look like me and sound
like me that are contributing with the
economy of this country and they live in
the shadows so it's time to seal the
Border like she said put order let's see
who comes in and who doesn't and then
turn around and give dignity that
doesn't mean path to citizenship that
means to include them and make them
dignified members of our community thank
you
how does that not mean path to
citizenship in what in what way do the
illegal aliens in America lack dignity
that is not merely synonymous with
citizenship or a pathway to citizenship
in what way you're saying they're
contributing to the economy okay so
they're getting jobs it's not that
they're being kept out of getting jobs
like when the Irish came here and in New
York they put up signs Irish need not
apply because there was a prejudice
against the Irish that's not what's
happening Hispanics are getting a ton of
jobs in America that's why they keep
coming
is it they're not being allowed into
restaurants no they're being allowed
into any public accommodation they want
is it that they're not being addressed
by the political class no the political
class not only the Democrats who are
importing them by the millions every
year but the Republicans like Maria
Salazar they can't stop babbling about
the illegal aliens and how great they
are in fact Maria Salazar said that she
represents them
when did that happen
I maybe I'm a little bit thick maybe I'm
a little bit stupid it's been a while
since I took Civics I thought though
that the members of Congress represented
their constituents who voted for them
who voted in the elections who are
citizens who are members of that
political community
that by definition would exclude the
foreign Nationals who are illegally
residing in our country in contravention
of the most basic laws of our country
and what does she say she says I
represent them she does I'm sure she
does when these people tell you who they
are believe them says I represent the
illegals that's true
she doesn't represent you
she shows up to Davos she Pals around
with all the libs yeah she's got an R
next to her name maybe she votes the
right way look we have a thin majority
in the House of Representatives I'll
take what I can get
so that Republicans can maintain control
but you think she represents you you
crazy
she just told you she doesn't
she told you that she represents
foreigners
and she represents them
before she represents you if she
represents you at all she represents
them first and she goes to their parties
first and she speaks on their fancy
panels first and she she is she is dead
set on giving them dignity the world
economic forum is dead set on taking
away your dignity
and and the best you can say is we need
to give foreign criminals
more dignity more than we've already
given them which is quite a lot more
than we've already recognized which is
quite a lot
I'll wrap up my little wef rant with a
turn to another kind of squishy guy but
he's not a squish as a republican who is
basically a Democrat he's a Democrat who
is largely a republican that would be
Joe manchin who said that we got a real
problem in our country here in the
United States he said this before a
crowd at the world economic forum and
you know what that problem is a free
press
the problem we have is the Open Press
system and basically all the platforms
so if you're able to have five platform
social platforms that you can basically
personify the extremes somebody who is
extremely right or extremely left and it
seems like that is the majority speaking
they're not the majority but they're
basically driving everybody to make a
decision what side are you on are you on
this side or this side and in America
there's only one side the American side
it's not the Republican side or a
Democrat we should be coming together to
solve the problems from a different
angle
we should come together to solve the
problems but in order to solve the
problems you have to have a clear view
of what you want to accomplish in order
to do that you have to pick a side Joe
and so the Kumbaya talk of come on man
let's not have any labels
you know who doesn't want us to have any
labels the globalist set
because they don't want us to have any
power because they don't want us to have
any Vision they want to Blind us they
actually want to Blind us to what's
going on in society they want us to wear
glasses that will reduce our vision and
they brag about it on their website
and that's true of our physical vision
and that's true of our political Vision
too
come on that's probably that's our big
problem is is the Free Press first of
all we don't have a free press the Press
is a total corporate sham that chills
almost entirely for the libs okay that's
our that's our free present in this
country
so that I mean that's a bit of a problem
the problem is that our press is too
free they allow that they allow the
Republicans to say too much maybe not
for long though maybe not too long not
for for too long if the world economic
Forum gets its way I'm Michael knows
it's the Michael Knowles show see you
tomorrow
[Music]
foreign
[Music]